I don't know what I love I love how you
take calls on your show you just take
off how do you feel tabbed oh I assumed
there's not too many people calling like
talking [ __ ] like you're not getting
trolls and stuff no we had a guy thought
people have difference of opinion we get
some stuff talking stuff your friends
opinions fine but it's not come back
you're the worst comic ever you [ __ ]
suck you hacked and then hang up or
anything I don't know I haven't I
haven't got much of that you're gonna
get a lot of people crying jerking off
we got a couple of dudes [ __ ] and
know even boy smells yeah I have to do a
voice mails
yeah people leave voicemails and then we
play them back oh that's super smart
yeah cuz some of these [ __ ] mooks you
can't have him just running no I figured
you had a producers control it like all
right caller 7 yeah we got we got Jamie
and doubts Jamie what do you got for the
300 ton of coke and pull it out you
started a lot like you and are we gonna
make it you know gonna make it at least
two years in a row baby yeah you got at
least two years in yeah I guess it's
something like that man yeah it's just
people just jure it's a lot of dudes
that are just addicted to jerking off
mostly and just struggling struggling
with jerking off all the time
bro that stuff's killing people I think
well your boy they do what you guys do
you jerk-off Jen
of course man wow she looks like a
sinker really he does you really I could
never picture an Asian guy doing it when
I picture to my head it's always a white
guy doing it yeah yeah I'd be honest me
too it's usually a white dude in the
corner interest in Shane over just like
know what like you what that's when I
picture dude my mom caught me when I was
young he opened when I was jerking off
right fool like I was having a party bro
yeah oh I planned it bro I just had an
alarm you know what are you drinking
often oh just just the pure imagination
bro just last week your imagination no
this is beckon imagination was good bro
yeah had all the fill of the trunk you
know that yet oz low and I had all the
filters on my brain and I was jerking
off to I picture you as a kid with a
mullet and you got you kind of you
looked a little bit like Joe Dirt and
you got like real short cut off G
your dicks hanging out the front and you
got this mullet and you're like dirty
you just got your socks on and you just
jacking off to like tool or something oh
my that's how I first of all thank you
that's kind of the coolest things I've
heard of dude I would jump up and down
and jerk off on my bed my thing was to
jump to jerk off and also be jumping on
the bed at the same time a trampoline
because it would get your butt blot
blood going in your body and then you
spray out farther oh wow that makes
sense
oh dude you can [ __ ] I mean you could
put a [ __ ] you could put a silk
mustache on a plant you know a plant
wants to drop side pocket boy you could
put that [ __ ] you could throw a you
know a beautiful little you know a
little uh just a white word Kurt and you
could drop that [ __ ] mustache on a
plant from about eleven feet away
was there any but I didn't porn as a kid
I didn't have magazines I'm at a cover
of this female rapper and Mercedes she
was bent over like a Cadillac after that
oh yeah yeah but you wrote with you jack
on when you were young I mean I remember
if I saw like a what I remember my
buddy's mom had a brassiere one time
that she would leave hanging in the
bathroom not just going there Brazil Oh
bro I would tie it around my [ __ ]
face so that each cup like leaned over
like right and weird love a little bit
of nose but the nostrils were covered so
just the middle all this this just that
main Saatchi to kill and versace sure we
protect your nose taint what is this
thing that little part your septum no
it's your name isn't it a little guy a
little bit you'd cover up so you can
almost restrict your breathing Oh bro so
I had a brief solely through these
[ __ ] just these straight up titty
heels yeah oh that's what I used to like
it's [ __ ] milk holsters broca's smell
the milk I could smell the skin I could
smell the nipple I could smell the
children I could smell all the years and
my buddy growing up it all dude go
straight at my head baby and I do it I
would jerk when I was on when I was
young
when I would masturbate I'd pass out
almost like that movie butterfly effect
yeah go back in time did he do that from
jerking off no he gets a bloody nose and
does it did imagine if every time you do
it you went back yes so all these dudes
just keep showing up there's yes imagine
we went back to what you were thinking
about man it was so much more powerful
then now it's just like yeah it's cuz
it's overrated you joined the 10,000
club you know I'm saying yeah like those
guys who hit 10,000 home runs do you
think they give a [ __ ] better than
homeruns anymore
probably not he'll get sold yeah a lot
you talking about life now yeah like
breathing no Cal Ripken now my dick yeah
yeah the Ted Williams jacking off yeah
it's too much tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]